republican congressman byron donalds is
accusing the congressional black caucus
of some serious bias he says the group
is blocking him from joining because of
his conservative political views
and cnn is trying to defend the move by
blasting donald
for supporting the former president
another donald
but then he shot back with this
as a black man in america i'm allowed to
have my own thoughts on who i choose to
support and who i choose not to support
i think that it's important whether
you're talking about the congressional
black caucus
or the florida state legislative black
caucus or the national
caucus of state black legislators
organizations i have been a part of in
the past
and donald's teeing off on the left and
media
on america reports great show the left
always talks about and the media always
likes to talk about how america is
intolerant
but it seems the only person only group
that's intolerant is them
let people have their own thoughts their
own ideals whether you're white you're
black hispanic
whether you're male or female that's up
to you people should be free to actually
communicate their thoughts and ideas
and stand by them they shouldn't be
ridiculed or excluded because of them
uh lawrence isn't that what we're
supposed to believe
is isn't that how we're raising our
children
to make sure that that every voice is
heard you know i hear you lawrence
a couple of things here first of all he
attended an hbcu
right he invests back into the community
he's a businessman
he talks about that i've had him on
several times to really push him on that
because i think it's important we have
strong leadership on the issue
she didn't bring him on to talk about
that what she did was which is what they
always do
because apparently trump broke the media
is that she
planned all played all these sound clips
and said what do you defend the
president
the interview wasn't even about that but
this is what they do they don't want to
talk about the issues they don't want to
talk about how to make
uh life for black america better let's
put this on donald trump
it's fine if the cbc uh the
congressional black caucus
doesn't want to invite him in i think he
should start his own caucus
and invite new people in that believe in
liberty and want to rescue
our community from the devastation that
they have had
meanwhile they're sitting there in the
middle of the rotunda
kneeling with kente cloth with nancy
pelosi but not
challenging her on the policies that are
coming out of congress that are harmful
for
black america gwen i think the the
congressional bloc caucus is strong
enough to have
a member who's got a different point of
view um and and this is the first time a
lot of people
are seeing this new congressman is it
cnn's fault greg
oh absolutely i think uh uh briana
thought she could
eat him alive like a plate of cicadas uh
thank you for bringing that up yeah yeah
yeah she
by the way she always looks like she's
suffering from the indigestion or gas
right from the sequence she's like while
he was talking
well it's just like this no comment
she's like different faces like this the
whole time
cnn is becoming more racist every day
they believe
that you can only be a certain kind of
black and if you aren't well
this very dismissive frowning white lady
can pass judgment on you and run these
little clips and make you feel like crap
cnn is in free fall right because they
hate they they
they were getting a decent rating as
they hate trump network right
but trump's gone and you so who do you
hate you hate everybody else
you hate you hate you hate trump voters
because they're still around you hate
republicans you hate religious
religious conservatives or religious
even democrats you hate black
conservatives that's clear
cnn should merge with crt
critical race theory and they should
change their name to crn
what do you say to that zucker he's uh
you know what that's going to go on the
white board juventus would be there
oh he's all over it we don't need
anything he's hanging
[Laughter]
subtle messages to the control room so
jessica
you know is the congressional black
caucus being
i don't know biased here so the
congressional black caucus has had
conservative members before mia love was
a member of the caucus not too recently
she only lost her election a couple
years ago and they've had other
conservatives in the past so this is not
a general check that box
well to some i mean there aren't that
many black elected officials on the
republican side it's kind of
it happens every once in a while and it
looks like it's going to be happening a
lot more we certainly saw a wave of
diversity
in the 2020 election my understanding
and i understand and that their response
did not address it head-on but from what
i'm hearing the issue with congressman
donald's is actually that he voted
against the certification of the results
so they're not taking a stand about your
republican values they're taking a stand
about
american back what does that have to do
with black america what does that have
to do with the improvement of black
it has to do with the fact that the
congressional black caucus is an
organization that believes in democracy
and the values of the constitution
and the right i mean i mean it's such a
difference let me just
i listen to you just let me get it out i
and listen i'm not
i'm clearly not a member of this group
i'm just explaining what
i believe to be the rationale here which
is clearly not because he's a republican
or because he's black
or because he's black republican it is
because he
voted to delegitimize a 2020 election
that has been found in
every single audit to have been fair and
that is the problem with him
and not donald trump uh he was very
impressive on your show today he was
thank you america reports byron donalds
came on to respond to that interview
when asked directly his response to it
he said pretty typical
of other media outlets when he chooses
which is often
to join them he was asked finally in the
interview by john roberts you did a
great job with it
he was asked what do white liberals not
get about
african-american communities in this
country his response is
we have diversity of thought we
all have ideas on how to improve the
situation they are not all the same and
i thought that was really important
that he got that message out there as
far as poor communities he said why
why right now is the other party the
democrats not talking about inflation
pocketbook issues
because this is what affects everyday
americans including the african-american
communities and he believes his
colleagues on the left are not directly
addressing
issues like that he takes issue with
that perhaps that's another reason why
jessica
well said sandra all right hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else